hi everyone so this is a another episode
of QA this time about science and
technology for kids and others so ask me
but if you want we'll see what I know
about there were a few questions left
over from previous sessions here so I
thought I might start off with a couple
of those so first question we had was
what happens when you sneeze in space or
turn on a flashlight in space okay let's
talk about both of these so first thing
is let's define sneeze where smees
inside your space students and STIs
inside the international space station
or sneeze directly into space let's hope
it wasn't directly into space because
then you would be very cold very much
without air and in very bad shape but I
think maybe what you are suggesting
let's talk about sneezing inside the
International Space Station okay so so
one feature of being in the ISS is that
you're weightless what does it mean to
be weightless so it means things don't
fall to the floor normally when we're on
the earth gravity makes things fall
towards the center of the earth but when
you're in the space station the space
station is orbiting the Earth and so
it's in a sense it's falling and if
you're inside the space station you're
just falling at the same rate as the
space station so relative to the space
station you're weightless
there's nothing pulling you down to the
bottom of the space station so to speak
because it's it's falling and you're
falling with it so for example if you
are in an elevator in a tall building
and the elevator is accelerating
downwards
you will feel not quite weightless but
you'll feel like you have less weight
because the elevator is kind of in the
bad case the elevator might be just
falling completely falling as if you
just drop the elevator if you were in an
elevator that was just falling which
wouldn't be a good good place to be then
you would be weightless relative to the
elevator and you would it would usually
just sort of floating
in the elevator but in something like
the space station it's kind of as it
goes around its orbit what the orbit is
is it's kind of the space stations
always falling towards the Earth but by
the time it would have fallen onto the
earth it's already around the side of
the earth and so it just goes around and
it's orbit and so relative to that you
inside the space station will just be
floating around not being pulled to the
floor so to speak okay so let's say you
sneeze well then what you're doing is
you're taking you're essentially you
could either sneeze or you could have a
ball and you throw the ball it's kind of
the same physics that's going to happen
the what's happening is there is a this
idea of conservation of momentum that is
when you if if you throw the ball you
are generating you're making that ball
have momentum going in a certain
direction and because of this principle
of conservation of momentum it will make
you go in the opposite direction so it's
like it's it's Newton's third law you
can you can describe it in a variety of
ways it's just a fact that's known about
physics that when there is if you sort
of are generating if you throw something
in one direction you will recoil in the
other direction so as to keep the the
total momentum momentum is is basically
the mass which it's officially in the
simple case at least it's mass
multiplied by velocity in order to keep
that constant if you push something one
way the the thing that pushes it goes
the other way so if you were to sneeze
then you would be you would be pushed
the other way now the amount you're
pushed the other way momentum is mass
times velocity and so your sneeze isn't
a large amount of mass it has a certain
velocity you're pushing your your sneeze
out with at a certain speed but it has a
certain mass it'll be quite small
compared to your mass so that means that
because what's being conserved is mass
times velocity the math says that
that if if the mass of the sneeze is
let's say a gram and let's say your mass
is I don't know two hundred is a hundred
kilograms that means that you weigh a
hundred thousand times as much as your
sneeze and so the to conserve this mass
times velocity quantity that means
you'll be pushed backwards a very small
amount relative to by by ejecting that
that gram of Sneed's okay so it's
actually the same kind of deal with a
flashlight a flashlight is the bulb in
your flashlight is producing light light
is a stream of photons and photons like
your sneeze has a certain have a certain
amount of momentum the amount of
momentum that photons have is quite
small but it is nevertheless not zero
and that means that in principle you
switch on your flashlight and it's
starting and it has a mirror that's
making all of the all of the photons
Bibi Shawn out for words so to speak
because that's what that parabolic
mirror that you'll see in a flashlight
is doing the bulb might be having
photons go in all directions but the
mirror is reflecting them so that
they're all going forwards so that means
that the momentum of the light the
momentum of the photons is all point in
the forward direction and so that will
mean that there's a recoil of the
flashlight by a very very very small
amount backwards now that that very
small amount of a recoil you can
actually use that because this idea that
there's momentum associated with light
they're places where you can use it so
actually it was that was recently done
to deploy a solar sail a giant sheet of
I think Mylar
a giant sheet of reflective material
very light sheet of reflective material
in space um you you you you unfurl this
thing and then you shine light at it or
for example use a light from the Sun but
you might shine a intense laser light at
it or you might use light from the Sun
either way there'll be a small amount of
pressure if the if the light from the
Sun for example is hitting the sail in
that direction the sail we pushed a
small amount
along by that by that momentum of the
light hitting it and actually this is
their sort of an idea it's been in
science fiction a lot and a little bit
of science fact now of making solar
sails where you could for example you
know tack out into the you could you
could sail out into the outer solar
system just pushed by the what's called
radiation pressure the the the the
pressure of photons from the Sun hitting
your your sail now the problem is the
Sun is not very bright
you know for us it's still a reasonable
you know it subtends a reasonable angle
in the sky
you know it's it's as big as our thumb
or something if you hold it out I think
that's roughly right if you were on even
Mars for example the the Sun is a as
much smaller and as you go further out
the the the the Sun ends up looking like
just a dot of light like another star
and although somewhat more intense for
anything in our solar system and so this
idea that you can use kind of light
pressure from the Sun looks a little bit
less plausible as you go further out
from the Sun so that was you know this
whole question of sneezes unfortunately
I've learned more than I would like to
know about sneezes as a result of things
about the virus I'll tell you a few
facts about about this so so one
question is when you when you sneeze you
produce a bunch of droplets of water
basically and those droplets are the
most common size of one of those
droplets is two microns two millionths
of a meter so that's about um how big is
that but that's some relative to a
period that you might see typed on a
page and that would be about C that will
be maybe a half a millimeter that's 500
microns so that would be um about one
two hundredth of the width of the period
but printed on the on the on the page
that that's the most common size for the
big droplets that you generate when you
sneeze they're actually a whole bunch of
much smaller droplets that you generate
as well when you sneeze what happens to
the big droplet
as they fall through the air they and
they fall just like if you threw a ball
it would fall so these droplets
similarly fall they don't fall quite as
fast as a typical ball would fall
because air resistance makes them
there's a lot more foot for a thing that
small it has some it the the amount of
of force that comes from gravity versus
the amount of a force that comes from
from air resistance makes it fall less
quickly I'm actually what's really weird
is that when you sneeze you generate a
bunch of smaller droplets going down to
maybe a tenth that size or less and
those much smaller droplets they
actually don't really fall in the air at
all in fact they are continually so it's
okay I have to explain one thing about
about so the air is made of a bunch of
air molecules nitrogen molecules oxygen
molecules they're all bouncing around
and they these molecules go a molecule
will be going a certain direction it
goes roughly at the speed of sound each
molecule in the air is going roughly at
the speed of sound
um but every they don't go very far
before they hit another molecule and I'm
I should be able to work this out if I
did a little bit of math I could work
out what's called the mean free path of
molecules in air I'm kind of thinking
it's about it's some fraction of a
millimeter I think for air at standard
pressure so that means that these tiny
atoms are going quite a distance before
they hit another with tiny molecules
going quite a distance before they hit
another molecule then they'll bounce off
that molecule and they keep bouncing and
when they keep bouncing they keep
bouncing around
they'll make what's usually called a
random walk they hit one one molecule
they bounce off it it bounces back their
bounce they're there they go in kind of
a random direction so they go in a
series of random directions and that
that process of bouncing off molecules
and going around and directions it's
often called brownie
motion after a chap called Brown who
discovered it in the eighteen early-ish
1800's he and that was actually that was
how people first understood that there
were got really good evidence that there
were atoms one of the two ways that
people really understood that there were
atoms was through seeing Brownian motion
because what they saw is they had a
little tiny pollen grains and they would
look at them in a fluid like water or
something and they would see that these
pollen grains would would you look at it
under a microscope they they keep on
getting kicked and these discreet the
fact that there were these discreet
kicks was a sign that was something
discreet and the water some discrete
molecules there rather than just that it
was a continuous thing in any case so
very very small particles water droplets
of water that you might sneeze will be
caught up in Brownian motion in the air
so instead of just falling like a ball
in a that falls like a parabola to the
ground instead there'll be these little
pieces of Brownian motion that will be
just continually kicking that a little
tiny bit of water around and it won't
fall to the ground it'll just stick
around and there are interesting videos
people have produced looking at this
it'll stick around for hours the thing
that makes it not stick around is air
currents so as soon as their air
currents like you open a window push the
whole thing will be it's a very light
thing so it will get any any draft of
air will just blow it around all over
the place so no case that's why it's one
of the reasons why people say it's
worthwhile to to kind of open windows
and things to get rid of things that
might be infected by the way if you're
curious the virus that we're all unhappy
about is about a hundred nanometers
across so that's some that's about one
tenth of a micron one tenth of a
millionth of a meter across that's the
size of the little Kotov of protein that
encloses the the RNA of the virus and in
fact what happens is it will be in
these water drops and actually the drops
the water will evaporate away and you'll
be left to just this pure virus and if
you just had this pure virus in the air
it will be kicked around by Baron in
motion it would just stay in the era the
good news is without a coat of water
I think the virus dies pretty quickly so
even even though it's it's there in the
air you don't have to worry about it
because it's not going to be able to
replicate there was a long answer the
question about sneezing in space okay um
okay the okay we have a question from
John H 14 here about what is a
hypersphere okay so I think I showed an
example before about things in in more
than three dimensions but let me let me
start off you know there's a there's a
really good example that I can control
or we get to that actually I know let's
get to the other questions in it let me
let me show you an actual example I've
got a nice way to show this which I
think works really quite well let me
just my screen here and let me pull
something up um let's see here okay let
me go like this alright so the basic
answer
as a hypersphere it's a sphere in more
than three dimensions so you know we
live we think in three-dimensional space
what does that mean it means we can go
forwards sideways up now forwards
backwards left right up down there's a
three separate directions that we can go
in in space we can't if we lived if if
we were kind of little creatures that
live just on on the surface of a on just
on a plane on the surface we might only
be able to go in two dimensions we would
only be able to go forwards backwards
left right we wouldn't be able to go up
down we just we just we couldn't get out
of that plane so to speak but um so a
question is what happens if we is it
possible to have more than three
dimensions so in our universe right now
so far as we know we basically live in a
three-dimensional universe
you know I've sort of a it's a strange
thing but I happen in recent months to
been working a lot on sort of
fundamental theory of physics and that
which I'm going to be talking about a
bunch more probably next week the in
that theory there are a lot of these
questions like why is space
three-dimensional we actually get to
have answers to those questions and
actually that theory suggests that there
may be little perturbations where space
isn't exactly three-dimensional and they
may have all kinds of consequences for
our universe but in a first
approximation the way we experience
things space is three dimensional
okay what does it mean to be three
dimensional four dimensional whatever so
here's a way that I've found it's quite
useful to to kind of see this okay so
this is oops I took the wrong thing um
okay so this is a grid and we would
normally say this is a two dimensional
grid it's two dimensional because we can
go left right we can go up down here
um we could as well have a a one
dimensional grid which is just where we
can just go left right we can't go in
any other direction so this is a one
dimensional grid because there's just
one one direction we can go in one
independent direction we can go in this
two dimensional so now let's do let's
make a three dimensional one of these so
we can say um make a grid a six by six
by six grid and now we have see I can
probably make this so it's obviously 3d
um that this is okay so here we have
something which we can rotate around and
we can see that it is what we would
normally call three dimensional okay but
let's take a look at the actual
structure of these things so let's say
we say we'll make a a square like this
and in the square every from every
corner of the square there are two
neighboring corners two neighboring
points let's do the corresponding thing
in 3d so if we do so this is a two
dimensional square in three dimensions
we have a cube and in that three
dimensional cube the if we look at each
corner of that three dimensional cube it
is adjacent to three other corners so
that are in the like often these
directions are called the X Direction y
direction Z Direction up-down left-right
in out for example okay so the obvious
thing we might do is to say great that's
a three dimensional well this will be a
three dimensional cube what would a
hypercube look like what would a four
dimensional cube look like and so we can
just say show us this thing that
connects where we are where we're making
something in which every corner
effectively is connected not to three
other corners but to four other corners
okay so this object is
as the structure of a four dimensional
cube often called the hypercube or
sometimes called the tesseract this
thing has the structure of a four
dimensional cube now you can see it's
it's some every every corner is joined
to four other corners now if if we can
draw this thing we can draw a
representation of this in here I'm
drawing it just in two dimensions I
could make this a three dimensional
representation and I could then rotate
it around and this is kind of drawing in
three dimensions something which is in a
sense really four dimensional just like
if you make a picture of a part of a
sphere for example you can draw a
picture of it on a 2d point two
dimensions where you might use shading
and things to give you a hint about
what's happening in the in the third
dimension so similarly what we're doing
here is we're drawing a four dimensional
object and we're rendering it well
ultimately in two dimensions but I'm
showing it kind of as a three
dimensional thing here so that's that's
what it means to have a a a
four-dimensional hypercube it's a thing
where every corner on a cube every
corner has three corners adjacent to it
on a hypercube in four dimensions every
corner has four corners adjacent to it
and we can have a five dimensional hyper
cube where every corner has five corners
adjacent to it and so on so that's
that's how we would invent these objects
which we can think about mathematically
in in more than three dimensions now in
the case of a of a sphere a sphere
normally is is something that exists in
three mentions a sphere is is the set of
points you get where you start look at
start from the center and then you just
say what are all the points that are the
same distance away from the center okay
so like a sphere of a radius one would
just be a thing where you're looking at
every point in three-dimensional space
that is a distance one away from the
center you do exactly the same thing in
four dimensions you can say make me
something where every I'm looking at all
the points that are let's say distance
one away from the center but
not in three dimensions with three
coordinates but instead in four
dimensions so that's what a hypersphere
is and you may know the formula in three
dimensions the the the volume of a
sphere is 4/3 PI R cubed that's that's
the that's the formula for the volume in
three dimensions there is similarly a
formula for volume in in in four
dimensions but let's actually talk first
of all about the volume in two
dimensions the volume in two dimensions
is actually just the area in two
dimensions so for a circle the quotes
volume of a circle which happens to just
be its area
it's just PI R squared so there's the
sequence in two dimensions the formula
is PI R squared in three dimensions it's
for third parts 4/3 PI R cubed and so
you might reasonably guess you might
wonder what is the volume of a sphere in
d dimensions and let's see if I can say
volume of D dimensional mullets chord D
dimensional ball let's see if we know
that not looking promising
see I think I should just type it
directly into off alpha um well but I
can I can do to do this um how long here
let us go to an alpha there we go let's
say volume of 4 D sphere um and this is
going to Oh tricky tricky tricky okay so
when mathematicians talk about a this is
a tricky thing okay
mathematicians when we talk about a
sphere when we're not doing fancy math
we usually mean a thing like a ball
that's just this sort of solid object
that is round okay
when mathematicians talk about what they
would call a when mathematicians are
talking about this ball they usually
call it a 2 sphere why do they call it a
sphere they call it a to spare because
it's surface
is two-dimensional the whole volume is
three-dimensional but its surface is
two-dimensional and it's as if you took
a plane a flat two-dimensional thing and
rolled it up then you get a two sphere
so-called s2 so when they talk about a
this is this is saying assuming a sphere
in five dimensional space actually we
want a sphere in 4-dimensional space so
what I'm gonna show you here this is the
volume of a sphere in 4-dimensional
space is PI squared R to the fourth over
two so it's PI squared over 2 R to the
fourth so that's the analog of 4/3 PI R
cubed in 3 mentions is PI squared over 2
R to the fourth and for people who are
if you really want to get fancy see if
we know this um the ah we do not know um
let's see if we say D dimensional sphere
I don't know what we're talking about
here
um the there's a formula
no we do not know what we're talking
about there okay there is a formula for
the volume of a d-dimensional sphere
which comes out in terms of factorials
it's it's always part of the D but it's
multiplied by the factor that will be
4/3 pi in the case of three dimensions
and it's PI squared over two in four
dimensions is a different factor in
different numbers of dimensions and
actually see how we can compute this
well I could go look it up because I
know where I've written it down um let's
see I will just see if I can get a good
good answer here um I has a good place
to get it from
Oh actually yes our mathworld site has a
nice thing on it okay so one of the
things let me show you one thing so this
is all fancy calculus that allows you to
work out the volume of a of a
d-dimensional sphere
here's one little interesting fact so
that pre-factor the thing that for a for
a circle disk is it's just pi PI R
squared
it's 4/3 PI R cubed for a sphere it's PI
squared over 2 out of the fourth for a 4
sphere that prefactor that thing with
PI's in it you might think oh as as you
increase the dimension that that will
always increase or decrease or something
bizarrely that that prefactor actually
has a maximum around I think this is
saying 7 dimensions 7.2 dimensions
just a weird math fact okay let's go
back to so that was sort of an
explanation of what a hyper sphere is um
and the let's see I think um what else
to say about hyper spheres I would say
that the we don't know at a mathematical
level it's all fine to make make hyper
spheres we don't know if one can make
those physically in the universe we
don't know if for example the whole
universe could be what our three
dimensions could be wrapped around a
higher dimensional sphere potentially
okay let's see there was another
question here is a single virus enough
to get you probably the answer to that
is no probably the answer is it's it's
thousands to even millions of virus
particles that you need there is some
from what I gather there is okay so so
what happens is
once the virus infects one of your cells
it kind of takes over that cell and it
starts replicating itself and so what
happens is first there will be one virus
then there'll be two then that we double
that number four then there'll be double
that number eight and the number of
viruses if if your immune system or
something else doesn't go attacking it
will roughly double every I don't know
how fast this virus replicates every
thirty minutes every hour or something
like that um and so it increases
exponentially doubling doubling all the
time um so you might think then that
well it doesn't matter if you just start
off with one virus then you know it will
by it doesn't take very long to get to a
thousand viruses I happen to know that
two to the power 10 is 1,024 so that
means that after 10 replications from
starting from one virus you would have a
thousand viruses ten doublings you'd
have a thousand viruses so you might say
why does it make any difference you
start off with a thousand or you start
with one I don't completely know the
answer to that um I think that it is
likely that well there are defenses that
your body has and also just the
probability the chance that a virus
successfully gets into a Cell is
certainly not a hundred percent um there
is some medical evidence last few weeks
that you get more sick if your initial
ingestion of viruses is with a larger
number of viruses I don't really
understand how that would work although
maybe there are some arguments about the
way your immune system attacks the virus
and sort of how the competition between
your immune system attacking and the
number of viruses replicating works but
I don't completely understand that but
the answer is one tiny virus particle
shouldn't shouldn't cause cause you
trouble
okay question here from Paulo what is
the most curious property of prime
numbers the most curious property apart
numbers there's so many curious
properties well here's one that I was
surprised by recently so if you look at
so prime numbers numbers that only have
what you can't divide exactly by
anything except one so numbers like
seven eleven but not numbers like nine
and ten which have which can be factored
um so the the fraction of numbers that
are prime gradually decreases as you
increase the number it goes down roughly
logarithmically but one question that I
happened to notice a while ago if you
look at the average distance between
primes for four numbers for fairly small
numbers like numbers less than a
thousand or something the average
distance between primes is six okay the
most common you know that you get a
different distribution of distances and
and the most common is six so like
eleven well the next one is 13 but if it
was if it was seventeen there'd be six
apart okay so you might have thought
okay so four numbers less than let's say
a million the most common difference
between primes is six okay you might
have thought that will last forever but
it doesn't gradually as you get to
larger and larger numbers the average
distance between primes gets a bit
bigger bit bigger bit bigger never stops
actually okay I'll mention another
another property of primes that you
might find find fun so I mentioned that
the density of primes gradually
decreases as you as you make numbers
bigger the fraction of numbers that a
prime gradually goes down it goes down
like the thing the logarithm of the size
of the number doesn't the logarithm is
just if you are saying let's not talk
about what that is the the I just say
that
the logarithm to the base 10 of a
thousand is three the logarithm to base
10 of a million is six a billion is nine
it's the it's the number of times you're
multiplying by ten to get to the number
you want that that number of times you
multiply is the logarithm of the number
and so the that that means you can get
to a very big number without and and
still have a fairly small logarithm okay
so there's a there's a fact about prime
numbers that the number of primes the
density of primes is always I'm not
going to get at the right way around is
always a less than or greater than this
this thing that's given by this
logarithm and that's true for any
reasonable sized number you work it out
on a computer you'll get you'll find it
out it's true but actually there are
numbers that are in for incredibly
incredibly huge numbers numbers like 10
to the 10 to the 100 that's that's like
a a 1 with a 1 with let's see a billion
billion billion billion billion billion
billion billion zeros after it so very
big number for a number that that big
this fact about the density of primes
flips around is no longer true so it's
really surprising that there can be
something that is sort of just talked
about in terms of primes where it's true
for almost four numbers up to even
absolutely huge numbers but it isn't
always true and it's a it's an
interesting fact about math that things
like that can happen that you can think
something is true for you know almost
every number for numbers up to huge
sizes but until you've actually got a
formal proof something where you can
just deduce from this step to that step
to that step that it's true you're not
sure it's true for every possible number
and that's a lot of the effort and pure
mathematics has to do with making these
proofs
you know they teach small versions of
those in in school the reason that
proofs of things that might seem obvious
are still worth doing is that you might
it's some to sort of deal with the
really in
Finnick case you need one of these
proofs that probably there are lots and
lots of other properties of prime
numbers but let's let's go into
something else um
uh okay it's a question here do you
think kids should approach computers as
if they're magic
or we should encourage them to
understand how they work and does this
apply to things like Mathematica you
know one of the things that happens in
sort of human progress is that we
automate more and more stuff there's
more and more things that we don't
individually ourselves have to do I mean
back in the day you know let's say you
wanted to write something on a piece of
well you didn't have paper let's say you
wanted to write something on a on a wall
of a cave or something like this well in
order to do that you'd have to make your
own paint and then you'd have to you
know go and figure out where it's going
to be painted how long it's going to
last all those kinds of things you know
the the progress of civilization and
technology is all about kind of
automated things like that away so that
we can kind of take for granted that a
bunch of stuff works so we can kind of
concentrate on the next things that
haven't yet been figured out how to do
so you know it there was I think it
might be surprising to people that the
fraction of people in the world who grow
their own food has gone dramatically
down for example in the past century you
know it might be that you know one could
would expect that if you want to eat
stuff you'd have to grow your own food
but we have this whole infrastructure a
whole mechanism for sort of in a sense
automating that away as part of
civilization so similarly if we want to
work out the answer to some let's say
math problem well how do one do it and
you know the first people who we know
did a lot of elaborate math problems
with the Babylonians and we know
starting about 4000 years ago that term
there was people did school math
exercises and these school math
exercises are are interesting to look at
from the Babylonians because they're
unbelievably similar to the exercises
that are done today the only difference
is that some of the stuff they talk
about about bushels of oil or amounts of
barley and things like that
maybe in most parts of the world those
the common version of word problems in
math it's really fun to look at what
kind of Babylonians school children so
to speak did you know the Babylonians
are a civilization about which we know a
lot because they had this special
feature that they wrote things down on
clay tablets and those Koyuk tablets are
well preserved and so while there were a
bunch of other civilizations that
probably existed at the same time they
didn't have written records that we now
have but for French from Babylon we have
lots and lots of these clay tablets and
these clay tablets describe lots of
things for example they describe math
and and they they have a in their
mathematics we use base 10 for example
to represent numbers so like the number
you know 123 is three units two tens and
104 the Babylonians they used base 60
which means their units were that
represented ones there next were
represented six days and the next
represented 60 times 60 well you might
notice that one vestige of Babylonian
ISM that still exists in the world today
is the way that we count time and that
comes directly from the Babylonians the
fact that there are 60 minutes in an
hour I'm not sure if the Babylonians had
seconds the fact that there are 60
seconds in a minute this is the
Babylonian number system shining through
into modern times but the Babylonians
had pretty sophisticated stuff that they
did with with numbers and they they
understood they were very very obsessed
with reciprocals 1 over a number because
they had a way of calculating things
that involved that and they wrote out
tablets of tables of reciprocals and so
on but anyway back in the time of the
Babylonians if you wanted to do a piece
of math you were really doing it you
know you were perhaps some you know
sometimes there's some scratch work
that's even preserved in these clay
tablets sometimes there are exercises
that people did on these clay tablets
4000 years ago but we can say today
whoops you got that a little bit wrong
um but you know we know
this was this we know kind of how the
math was done even at that time they had
very elaborate math I Eve actually
recently learnt they had a whole scheme
for computing the position of the moon
and that scheme was based on having sort
of functions that were in zigzag shapes
and adding together lots of different
zigzag functions to figure out where the
moon would be very similar if if you are
aware of the history of science to the
way that epicycles worked in the
Ptolemaic system for understanding the
solar system actually in today's world
when we compute the position of the moon
we're doing it in a computer using where
we add up series of 10,000 different
things that are a little bit like the
Babylonian zigzag functions but they
actually had a whole procedure for
computing the position of the moon very
much like our programs today but that's
something that was sort of lost over the
course of the millennia until more
recent times but any case so back in
Babylonian times you want to do some
math you're doing it yourself
well steadily there were various kinds
of tools that were invented back when I
was a kid there were things called slide
rules that were these things I would get
up and go fetch my slide rule but Tim
let me just sort of explain how they
worked they were just these things where
you have these two two things that slide
back and forth that have scales a little
bit like rulers on them but they had a
little clever feature the rulers were
marked actually using logarithms and the
way things work when you add logarithms
that corresponds to multiplying numbers
and so it's like when you slide these
slides and you read off what what number
is on top of what other number you can
use that to figure out what the what the
multiplication of two numbers what the
the product of two numbers is so back
when I was a kid believe it or not
people were still using slide rules and
it was like how fast could you do it and
it was a very manual kind of thing there
were also mechanical calculators that
used cogs and gears and so on to to do
arithmetic then around 1970 electronic
calculators came in and and things
changed very rapidly actually
few years so nowadays you know you want
to do a piece of let's say mathematical
calculation you don't have to do it out
by hand and work it all out you can just
use a calculator or a computer to do it
and you know that is progress and the
fact that you can use a computer to do
it means you can do a million pieces of
arithmetic and when you do a million
pieces of arithmetic you can do make all
kinds of fancy things out of it you can
make all kinds of interesting pictures
you can try to understand what's going
on and so on so I would say that the the
the the main thing to to say is that it
is the the great thing in a sense about
the progress of civilization is that we
build this taller and taller stack of
what's automated now you can ask is it
worth knowing how a computer works
inside it's a pretty specialized thing
to know how a computer works inside I
think it's pretty interesting but it is
a pretty specialized thing just just for
fun maybe I'll talk a little bit about a
bit a little bit about how a computer
works inside you know back even a few
years ago you could readily take
computers apart it's become more and
more difficult to take computers apart I
do recommend I don't recommend you do
this don't do this kids don't take apart
some computer because you won't be able
to put it back together again um at
least I dad there and and you'll you'll
the manufacturer will never touch your
computer after you've opened it up and
things but um particularly for desktop
computers you you potentially can take
them apart it's more difficult with
laptops what will you see if you take a
computer apart well you'll see um the
you'll see a bunch of will you'll see
typically a printed circuit board that's
a thing where they're essentially a
bunch of wires that have been sort of
printed on to a board to carry
electricity between different places and
then you'll see these chips these things
that you'll see probably the plastic
coating of the chip and you might see a
whole bunch of pins that stick out of
the chip on each side that's the main
heart of the computer they they're
really the the the central piece of a
computer is called its CPU its central
processing unit that's the thing that
sort of does does most of the computing
in a computer ok what is the central
processing unit and how does it
if you were to slice the top off that um
it's it's contained in plastic um but if
you were to slice the top off and do it
very very very carefully because usually
these things are for variety reasons
they're made so they're pretty hard to
UM to slice open and look inside if you
looked inside you would see a kind of a
dull metallic thing maybe I don't know a
couple of centimeters across
typically um and might look like pretty
much nothing but if you would look at it
under a powerful microscope you would
see something that looks like a city map
but a city map which kind of on the
scale of of streets that would be in a
typical city it would be like sitting
map covering the whole earth it's a lot
of little tiny little tiny streets going
all around different places and that
that is the circuitry that is what what
operates the computer how does that
circuitry work well you'll see if you
looked at this CPU chip you would see
different sections so one section that's
reasonably easy to understand is the
memory of the computer that that part of
the memory well there'll be a on the on
the CPU chip they'll usually be some
some local memory some local ran local
random access memory um and what is that
well what that's doing is it's storing
all kinds of things that you're
computing so for example it might be
storing all the pixels all the colors of
pixels that you're going to put on the
screen at the next moment or it might be
storing the words that you have in a
document that you have in a word
processor could be storing any kind of
data so one of the things that sort of
makes computers work is that all of this
different kind of data that we look at
whether it's an image on the screen
whether it's text whether it's audio all
these different kinds of things at the
level of the computer chip they're all
ground down into just individual bits so
for example a and the way that that
works is that in the end every
the way computers store things is they
basically store kind of like numbers at
the lowest level they're just storing
zeros and ones but usually those are
clumped together and what I call bytes
and a byte is eight bits eight zeros and
ones and in eight zeros and ones you can
store any number from zero to 255 0 to
255 so the bytes in a computer are
basically storing numbers between 0 and
255 and in your computer like well my
computer I think has some about a
hundred gigabytes a hundred billion
bytes the one on my desktop at least has
about a hundred billion bytes of memory
and so that means it can store a hundred
billion bytes of data so for example
your screen might be if it's a
reasonably high resolution laptop screen
it might have let me just work it out it
might have about it might correspond to
a few million maybe it tens a maybe 10
million bytes of data to represent for
every little pixel on your screen what
color it is might altogether take um ten
million bytes or something like that um
and so anyway the ultimately all of this
data whether it's data about pictures
data about words whatever is stored in
bytes as these bits in the memory of the
computer so for example if you want to
take text every letter is assigned a
certain number so in the usual way of
doing things I think a lowercase a is a
time assigned the number 65 and the
lowercase B is assigned the number 66 if
I remember the numbers correctly maybe
that's a capital A I have to look it up
to be sure um but there's a there's a
sort of standardized code for every
letter so actually four letters just in
the standard English alphabet they all
fit in a thing called ASCII which just
uses one byte to store each letter and
there's a fancier thing called Unicode
which was invented in the 1990s as a way
to store all
the characters that show up in all of
the languages that exist on on earth and
you know there are there are characters
in languages like Chinese for example
there might be I don't know 40,000
characters instead of our usual 26
letters of the alphabet and there might
be in another in other languages there
are similarly well there are few other
languages that have it usually CJK
chinese japanese korean are the ones
that have tens of thousands of
characters that need to be encoded in
this unicode way of specifying
characters of text and actually the so
standard unicode stores a character in
not just one bite but two bytes um
and that that allows you to get the
characters that exist in that number of
bytes you have altogether 65,000
possibilities so you can store 65,000
different characters from the different
languages of the earth and it doesn't
quite get everything actually our
friends the babylonians i was just
mentioning who they're Kunia form that
they used for their writing system
didn't fit in ordinary unicode so
actually there's an extension to unicode
that allows you to make sort of extra
extra versions of this that for example
will fit can air form or actually in
modern times the real win of what's
called beyond claim 0 unicode is fitting
emoji because there are lots of emoji
and people want to put even more emoji
in and to specify all those different
emoji you need a larger number of slots
in your character set and so there's
been an extension to do that ok back to
back to computers and storing things so
all these things whether they're
characters emojis things on the pictures
on the screen whatever these are all
eventually stored as data stored and
bytes within each byte there are 8 bits
each bit is just a 0 or 1
ok so ultimately when you look at this
computer chip you will see this big area
of the chip that's just a giant array
of little elements and each of those
little elements stores just one bit and
what it's doing is each of each of those
little tiny elements on is is saying
whether a particular some particular
piece of data for your computer is a 1
or a 0 how does it store that ok it's
slightly tricky um let's see where do we
go here I mean ok I'll explain there are
different forms of computer memory that
so ordinary memory of a computer
ordinary RAM random access memory
it's called random access because you
can go and say I want the piece of data
that's that location of the memory for
any location you can immediately pick it
up the reason it's called random access
is back in the day a long time ago when
people well actually
okay when people were using tapes
magnetic tape to store things on
computers you might see in old movies
you'll see you know you'll sometimes see
the computer room and there'll be these
things that are you know these circular
things that are twiddling back and forth
those are those are tapes and they're
just too long if you unspool the thing
it's a big long you know big long thing
of tape magnetic tape and that's not
random access memory because if you want
to know what was at the other end of
your tape you have to unspool the whole
thing and to put it onto another another
spool of tape to go find that piece of
memory so that's not an example of
random access memory but so modern
computers their main memory is what's
called random access memory because you
can just get a piece of data out of
anyway you wants in the memory sort of
without having to spend lots more time
to get it from another part of the
memory so in typical random access
memory it requires that the power be
switched on on your computer for it to
keep its memory there's another that's
rather confusing all the terminology ROM
read-only memory and there's also other
things like
eeep rom erasable programmable read-only
memory these all these abbreviations but
but um that is something which even if
you switch the computer off it will
store its ones and zeros but it actually
works in more or less the same way as
ordinary RAM okay so how does Ram work
how does how does computer memory work
okay let's see let me say that the big
picture first and then we'll go into
more detail so every bit in computer
memory is stored using a collection of
transistors that are implemented using
this using the properties of the element
silicon as a semiconductor okay that's
kind of complicated but let me let me
try to explain essentially gosh this may
not be so easy to explain um what's
happening is that well all right this
isn't quite right but you can kind of
think of it as the no I'm not going to
okay let me let me put this a to the
side because it requires a little bit of
level of explanation of how the how the
memory is maintained but but basically
what's happening is that in in a very
rough approximation
you've kind of got electrical signals
that are just sort of recirculating
around and they just keep recirculating
around and when it represents a1 there's
an electrical signal there and when it
represents a zero there isn't that isn't
quite right but that's a first
approximation but let me explain let me
explain more about what's on the silicon
what's on this chip
okay so that
that thing that I said was kind of like
a like a giant city map that's
essentially a bunch of wires that are
taking that a connecting data together
that are that are implementing all the
operations in the computer so let's see
how to explain how this works okay let's
talk about first of all what operations
a computer fundamentally does so when
you type in let's say you type into
Wolfram language or something 2+2 what
does it actually do but it's actually
doing in the end is it's running kind of
a that two plus two that you type in is
translated ultimately into a long string
of what are called machine code
instructions the instructions that the
computer intrinsically knows how to do
so it's a it's an incredibly fundamental
fact that you can have a fixed machine
code for a computer and you can just by
writing different programs you can have
the computer do a whole range of
different things whether it's running a
video game or being a word processor all
these different things it's the same
underlying machine code instructions
that the computer has available to it
it's just the program that you've given
that says what sequence of machine code
instructions you're going to run that's
different between the video game of the
word processor and that's a fundamental
fact it's this fact that the existence
of universal computation was first
discovered in the 1930s wasn't really
made use of until the 1950s it's that's
a fundamental sort of mathematical fact
that's basically what makes modern
computers possible what makes software
possible and so on if that fact wasn't
true then the thing you would need to
run let's say a word processor or a math
computation system you'd need to just
buy a different computer because you
would have to have different machine
code instructions to do all those
different things but but this
fundamental fact that Universal
computation is possible means there's
one set of machine code operations then
it can be programmed to do all these
different things okay what are the
machine code operations
so they're very low-level things they
they will typically say things like well
for example actually adding numbers is
probably a machine code operation but a
more typical operation says get this
number from this location in memory and
get another number from another location
in memory add them together put the
result back into another location in
memory or another operation it's very
important is just go through the program
that okay so another critical fact about
computers is they can store data like
what's on your screen or what's in your
document and but one of the kinds of
data they can store is programs that
tell the computer what to do programs
can also be represented as data just
like the things on yours the words in
your word in your in your document can
be represented as data so also the
program that tells the computer what to
do can be represented as data and stored
by the computer and so one important
operation for the computer one
importance of a machine code operation
is just go to the next thing the next
instruction that's written down in your
program and go do what that instruction
says and so then another thing is to say
I've got to this instruction now jump
back to a previous instruction that's
something that allows you to make a loop
for the computer now honestly when you
are thinking as a human and trying to
program a computer you don't really want
to be down at the level of saying I want
this instruction to be executed next and
then I wanted to go back and jump to
this other one the further away you are
from all of that detail the more you're
going to be able to program interesting
things but as far as the machine code of
the computer is concerned it's operating
at that level of saying do this
instruction do this next instruction
pull this data from one place in memory
add it to another thing so in a typical
computer there are different styles of
computer so called reduced instruction
set and complex instruction set
computers but in a typical modern
computer there might be maybe let's say
on average a hundred
machine code operations a hundred
fundamental things the computer knows
how to do and so when it sees its
program way down at the level of what's
stored in its memory what it will see is
an opcode that says do operation number
17 which might be subtract numbers from
each other or something do operation 17
on memory locations six seven five eight
four and memory locations such-and-such
and put the results in memory location
session sets that's ultimately what the
computer is doing at the level of what's
called machine code okay so I mentioned
that there's memory in the in the
computer there's also there's also
another piece to the CPU which is
usually called the ALU the arithmetic
logic unit and that's the part that
doesn't just store things but computes
things actually does the addition and so
on it's the part that actually executes
these op codes it actually does the
operations that are specified by the op
codes okay so how does the ALU work well
it's a big really complicated circuit
and over the course of the last 50 years
basically people have built bigger and
bigger and more and more complicated
circuits so they have billions of
components now and it's been found out
what the the most efficient ways to like
add numbers together in bits and so on
are and so that ALU is is the thing that
is all those little tiny sort of wire
like things that you would see if you
looked at a at a chip under a microscope
and how does it how does it actually
work well at the lowest level all the
computer is doing is a single operation
over and over again and the results from
that operation are being fed into other
places and being taken to other places
and so on and the one operation that a
computer that any modern computer does
over and over and over again there's a
thing called NAND okay so let's explain
what that is so we have to explain a
little bit about logic first NAND is a
is a logic operation okay what is logic
so if we say logic is kind of a way to
represent sort of idealized way to
represent statements that you make about
the world
at least that's one way of thinking
about it so for example if I might say
if and say if it rains today what's a
good example um I might say my my phone
cover is red or my phone cover or my
phone is either red or it's black um and
that's so I can think of that as the
statement my phone is red
my phone is black those are two
statements I might call those statements
P and Q and I can then think of it as a
piece of logic that is P my phone is red
or Q my phone is black um and then I can
do I could say so I could say P or Q my
phone is red or my phone is black or I
could say P and Q my phone is black my
phone is red and my phone is black and
there are things that we can operations
we can do we can say things like it is
not true that my phone is is either
black or red if that is not true then it
follows that it is not black and it is
not red can go through that again so
that this is a this was invented this
whole idea of logic at least as far as
we know it was invented by Aristotle in
the 2nd 3rd century BC um and it's it's
something used to be taught along with
math as it used to be one of the big
subjects that was taught a few hundred
years ago in school math really won out
relative to logic but logic is is these
kinds of things where you say consider a
statement my phone is red and call it P
consider another statement my phone is
black call it Q and then we can sort of
do operations on that there are a little
bit like algebra there's a version of
algebra called boolean algebra which is
sort of an algebra for logic the
works differently from the algebra that
you do for for for numbers okay why am I
telling you all of this the because
inside a computer so I mentioned and I
mentioned not inside a computer the
operation that is that is implemented
over and over again is the not and
operation usually called NAND and so
what that what that means is that what
the what it means to be to implement it
is there are essentially wires that come
in and to say that you to say that you
saying that the wire either has
electricity on it or it doesn't so that
corresponds to it either has a 1 or a 0
the other wire has either a 1 or a 0 if
we were doing the and operation we will
be saying two wires come in they can
either be 1 or 0 and we say the and
operation would be the result is a 1 if
both the first wire and the second wire
have ones on them and the or operation
would be the the the output wire is a 1
if either one wire I had a one or the
other wire I had a 1 on it okay so the
NAND operation happens to be it is not
the case that both wires have ones on
them okay seems like an irrelevant kind
of weird thing ok nanus that seems like
kind of a a weird thing that might be a
footnote the footnote in a book about
logic and actually when nan was first
invented around 1900 that's kind of how
it was but then it turned out that
people discovered that was possible to
use semiconductors type of material to
implement nand operations to actually
make it so you could make these wires
and have it be the case that when the
wires come in and they have ones and
zeros on them that what comes out is the
knot and of what went in okay how are
those wires implemented there how are
those things implemented they're
implemented using things called field
effect transistors on in silicon I can
explain more or less how this works
roughly what happens is gosh I'm I'm
explaining a pretty big technology stack
here but but let me keep going because I
think I can actually I can more
get all the way to telling you how a
computer works um the so all right
let's imagine we have a wire and it's
just has an electric current going
through it so it's it's it has little
electrons that are that corresponds to
the electric current and they're flowing
from one end of the wire to the other
okay
let's imagine we have another wire
that's that's that sort of crossing over
that that wire and we haven't be the
case that if there is a voltage if
there's some if we sort of put a battery
across that that sort of wire that wire
goes across then we can with that
voltage if there is a voltage there it
will let's say prevent a current from
going through this wire if there isn't a
voltage it won't prevent it okay so this
essentially makes a switch we've
essentially made an electrical switch
where by by saying whether there is
voltage on one wire we're determining
where the current can go through the
other wire okay now it turns out that
with a combination of a few of those
switches we can make a thing where we
have a pair of wires and it will make a
NAND gate as it's called it's called a
gate because it's kind of like you're
opening and closing a gate depending on
whether this convert this voltage is
there or not okay so all right well
that's so essentially what we're trying
to do is we're trying to make these NAND
gates and the atom well personally to
say is why do we care about making NAND
gates the reason we care about making
NAND gates is NAND gate NAND is a logic
operation has an interesting property
that if you combine together NAND
operations you can make any other logic
operation so I don't remember what it is
but I think of if it's NAND of P and Nan
P NAND
peen and q or something let's say is the
equivalents of P and Q I don't think
that's quite right but it's something
like that but so by combining nand
operations together you can make any
other logic operation you want and so in
the circuitry of a computer every
operation the whole ALU is just made as
a giant combination of nand operations
that's all it's doing is billions of
nand operations which are all being
combined to make all the operations you
want to add numbers together or whatever
else okay so explaining how NAND
actually works so you've got these
things that called field effect
transistors Fe T's that are the actual
thing that that has electric currents
going through they're controlled by
voltages how do you make one of these
transistors well it's kind of clever
um the okay a little more explanation a
little bit of physics here so okay
chemical element silicon very common
chemical element it's rock is made of
that the primary thing rocks are
silicates silicon is a core piece of any
rock okay if you make silicon very very
very very very pure you can make
crystals of silicon that are more or
less perfect crystals where the atoms of
silicon are perfectly lined up at an
atomic scale and usually silicon doesn't
conduct electricity so metals for
example like I don't know copper or
something like that it conducts
electricity to make a wire out of it you
put a battery you put a battery across
it and it will make an electric current
flow through that wire silicon doesn't
have that property ordinary an ordinary
lump of silicon doesn't let you doesn't
conduct electricity but it is a
semiconductor and well they're couple of
there all sorts of different ways it's
just on the edge of being able to
conduct electricity and so they're all
kinds of detailed things you can do to
make it conduct electricity so one of
the things you can do is you can dope it
with a very small amount of some other
material so there are these different
kinds of dopants which are other
chemical elements
and you put tiny tiny concentrations of
these into silicone and they cause the
silicone to essentially be able to
conduct electricity in under certain
circumstances and essentially what
you're doing when you make one of these
little switches one of these field
effect transistors is you make a little
pattern of doping where you have a
little bit of layer I don't know indium
I think is one of the dopants some I
think maybe tin maybe a dopant I'm not
sure they're all kinds of different
different chemical elements it's kind of
a zoo of chemical elements you know you
see this whole periodic table you say
what would anybody possibly use you know
indium or something for well tiny
amounts of it are used as as as pieces
of sort of a sort of random what element
is useful because it depends on the
atomic properties of the element what
thing what elements is useful to to dope
silicon with so okay so then what you
what you're doing is you're you're
putting in these little tiny amounts of
these other elements and they change the
electrical properties of the silicon and
allow you to create these things like
field effect transistors these little
tiny switches which then can be
assembled into little tiny NAND gates
which can then be assembled after you
have a billion of them into a great big
ALU so okay so how do you actually how
do you actually make this some so that's
what this giant sort of cityscape is
it's all the little tiny places where
there isn't isn't dopant on the silicon
but there isn't isn't a piece of that
kind of wire that goes through and I'm
alighting a lot of details of how
semiconductors get made but but that's
that's roughly the idea so then then the
next question is how do you actually
make in a you know 2 centimeter square
how do you make all those little tiny
wires how do you actually get something
that small so the way it works says it's
kind of the reverse of what a projector
does so a projector you might have let's
imagine you have a slide projector
people even know what those are anymore
you know you have a little little slide
and you're projecting something in this
little tiny slide and the projector
projects out you have this great big
image you know in the front of the movie
theater or something like that so let's
imagine you ran that in Reverse
you had a big thing but you were sort of
d magnifying it you were using you were
just like with a bunch of lenses you
were just making it so that it you go
from a big image down to a tiny image so
what happens is when you make a silicon
chip microprocessor what you're doing is
you get this giant map that you actually
they I don't know what they how they do
it now but it they used to actually have
these these physical sheets of that were
essentially drawings of the map in
different layers and they would take
that giant drawing and they would
essentially be just D magnifying it down
onto this little tiny piece of silicon
and it turns out that the way it works
is usually it's done using ultraviolet
light but it could be done using visible
light it's it's some what what happens
is you take this image of the sort of
cityscape that you want you and you
project it onto this little chip much de
magnified and in places where there's
sort of a dark line
okay then another another thing you um
you have a material that's on top of the
silicon it's I think it's photoresist I
think it's called the where which has
the property that when ultraviolet light
falls on it on a particular part of it
you can etch it away with acid and when
it doesn't fall you can textured away
and so what happens is this sort of
giant picture of where you want all the
wires is projected very small and
ultraviolet light onto this piece of
silicon and essentially where the where
there was a dark line the when the acid
comes through it will etch it away and
where there wasn't a dark line it won't
touch it away let's say and what that
does is it will essentially edge out the
that cityscape that you had and it will
create all those billions of little
wires and so on and that's some that's
basically how a computer is made and
when what typically will happen is
you'll have this wafer of silicon it's
big very very pure silicon and on that
wafer you'll make a whole bunch of
little copies of that of the
microprocessor of the little of the CPU
chip
usually not all of them will work the
big issue in making semiconductors is
what's called the yield the question is
what fraction of those little
microprocessors that you make actually
work on a single on a single piece of
single wafer that you get out from a
single piece of silicon and usually
they'll you make them all you test them
you have little probes that come down
and test them you say this one's this
one's working fine you say this one's
working really well we'll sell that one
as a higher speed computer this one is
only working rather slowly that's a
lower speed one it's it's kind of like
mining you know different sizes of
diamonds or something anyway so that's
that is a really long description sorry
that would took a long time it's
computers are complicated I mean there's
there's more to say about how computers
work but that's at least a first first
approximation we're going from you know
all the data that including programs are
turned into these bits they're stored in
the memory they are the things are being
extracted from memory according to the
instructions in the machine code run
through the ALU which actually does the
computations the computations are done
using these circuits that are made out
of NAND gates that's kind of how
computers work all right let's see that
was really long um let's see there's a
question here okay uh is there
limit to how many dimensions you can
have very different question no there's
no limit just like I was saying that
every corner of our hypercube can have
let's say in four dimensions can have
four neighbors you can have a thousand
dimensional hyper cube it has a thousand
neighbors to every corner and okay if
you want to get really fancy you can say
what's the limit of a hypercube as it
has an infinite number of corners that's
a complicated thing it's some well it's
kind of like a hilbert space it's kind
of like a cantor set it's it's a it's a
bunch of fancy math some aspects of
which aren't very well understood but
that's but yeah you can have in a
mathematical level you can have a thing
with any number of dimensions next
question what is what is zero point two
dimensions let me know this is going to
get us into a long discussion of things
called fractals maybe we'll come back to
that let me let me keep going a little
bit on some of the other questions here
um okay we've got
from class what do you have to why do
you have to acquire a certain speed to
escape Earth's gravity to get into space
um okay well let's first we'll say
what's true and then I'll try and say a
little bit about the Y so first thing
that's true the escape velocity of the
earth is 25,000 miles per hour that
means if you threw something up
assuming you ignore air resistance and
so on if you throw a lock it up if you
make a rocket go up more than 25,000
miles an hour it will escape the Earth's
gravity and it can go floating off into
the into the solar system if it's less
than that if it has a speed less than
that it will eventually turn around and
come back down again and and come come
back down to the earth it might go into
orbit if you've if you've changed its
orientation you might it might go into
orbit around the Earth but the speed you
need to get it to escape the Earth's
gravity to get out of orbit to just go
away from the earth is 25,000 miles an
hour for the Sun it's a hundred thousand
miles an hour so the Sun is there's more
gravity associated with the Sun its
escape velocities around a hundred
thousand miles an hour probably the
biggest thing I know is the escape
velocity of the galaxies which is around
a million miles an hour to escape our
galaxy um and good question is what the
escape velocity of the universe is and I
kind of suspect the escape velocity of
the universe is the speed of light but
I'm not immediately able to to validate
that tell ya I think it has to be true
the escape velocity of a black hole is
the speed of light and I think it's also
true if you were to be sort of in some
sense outside our universe but I have to
think about the some fancy math to
figure that out for sure um but anyway
so for the earth why is there a certain
speed you need to go okay
gosh different ways to explain this um
you know when you ask a question about
why in physics it usually just
is back to being another you know
eventually you end up with some physical
law that it's just you're just told
that's just true about the world so
because I've been working on fundamental
physics I'm sort of hoping we can do a
little bit better than just go back to a
physical law and say that's just true
about the world um and actually in my
kind of approach to fundamental physics
I think we would have a slightly more
elaborate answer to this question of why
but I'll tell you the traditional
physics answer the traditional physics
answer would be this there is a certain
force of attraction between objects that
have mass it's a force of attraction
that's the result of gravity and that
force of attraction it's an inverse
square law as you as you make the make
the things twice as far apart it's some
two squared less force a quarter the the
gravitational force so the what's
happening is that you are well let's see
I mean that the usual physics way to say
it would be that the potential energy
associated with gravitation you need to
overcome that by having kinetic energy
associated with motion essentially what
you're doing is you're saying you it's
as if you were being how what's the best
way to say it you know all of these
things are really just going to come
back to saying it works that way because
there's gravitational force and in order
to in order to escape that gravitational
force you have to have a certain kinetic
energy a certain a certain velocity you
know I think there's probably a better
way to do this but I'm which it's going
to take me a few minutes of flailing
around here to get the optimal
explanation that involves minimum math
and I'm not sure I'm going to be able to
do that let's just let's just say that
that it's an it's easy to work out if
you know the formulas for how the the
acceleration due to gravity and how that
compares to the that generates a
gravitational energy that you have to
overcome
the way people think about it is it's
usually once says that things have
gravity wells it's as if this kind of a
you're being sort of there's this
there's this area that has sort of
gravitational where you're kind of at a
okay there is a way to explain this
using general relativity which might be
a little bit more more of a why answer
let me let me punt on this for right now
let me keep going because otherwise I'm
gonna get trapped in this particular
gravity well um for a long time here so
let me keep going all right there's a
question from Lewis on Facebook this is
a slightly Massey question says I've
seen Gaussian Prime's which are
two-dimensional primes what's the
equivalence in 3d okay I'm gonna I'll
answer this bill answer it fairly
quickly because the answer is going to
be kind of complicated so I talked about
prime numbers and prime numbers are
numbers that have the property that you
can't divide them by anything other than
themselves so number like seven as
opposed to a number like eight or you
can divide it by two and so on okay when
it comes to complex numbers which I'd be
happy to explain some time but I'm not
going to explain today you have well
complex numbers involve having things
like the square root of minus one added
to your ordinary numbers there's a
notion of primes for complex numbers as
well but the result the fundamental
theorem of arithmetic that there isn't
that there's a unique factorization am I
miss remembering this I don't think that
applies to Gaussian Prime's it doesn't
apply so there isn't just one way that
you can take a complex number complex
integer and write it in terms of complex
Prime's but that's what the Gaussian
Prime's are they're they're writing a
complex number like 3 plus I they're
asking can you write that as a product
of of other other other complex numbers
and so the question is what's the analog
complex numbers a way of representing
sort of pairs of numbers real and
imaginary part of a number in two
dimensions what's the analog in more
dimensions it's quite complicated so
there are things called quaternion
which effectively are like
four-dimensional things and there are
things called octo nians which kind of
like eight dimensional things and after
that you lose it the the the properties
of that that relates to these so-called
number fields no longer apply there are
their properties that that sort of allow
you to do things like like prime
factorization but they don't apply
anymore and there's a pretty elaborate
theory of how all that works even even
for the quaternions the notion of primes
is complicated and I think not all that
well studied so it gets it gets very
complicated very quickly and if you ask
for the pure three-dimensional case
there isn't really a pure
three-dimensional case just as a to say
one quick thing if you look at relative
prime allottee you can ask when is the
GCD of two numbers equal to one I'm
getting complicated here you can say you
can you can talk about that in terms of
triples of numbers and that's a way that
you can get something like prime
allottee in in three dimensions but
that's a relative primacy idea okay next
question here um somebody is wondering
about exporting from Mathematica 3d
plots into virtual reality actually I
think that works rather the the the real
problem with virtual reality so virtual
reality for people who don't know is you
know you wear this typically in the good
version you wear this big headset and
it's showing you an image in each eye
and because because it's showing you
potentially a different image in each
eye things really seem three-dimensional
normally when we're looking at a
computer screen we are looking at the
same image with both eyes and so because
the way that we perceive things in three
dimensions more or less uses the fact
that we're seeing the things from
slightly different angles from our two
eyes and that's why our brain kind of
sort of synthesizes that into oh that's
a three dimensional object well we can
simulate that using in virtual reality
by having a slightly different image in
each eye it's sort of challenging
because there are an you know wet went
the way it works is the VR headset has
an accelerometer
so it knows when you're turning your
head and it can figure out how to sort
of make the make the image be locked in
place even though you're turning it but
we be able to you can be able to see
different things as you turn your head
unfortunately if there's even the
slightest lag and when you turn your
head and when you see a different image
it it produces some kind of motion
sickness and actually for me I have a
really hard time using virtual reality
stuff for more than a few minutes
because it makes me motion sick and I've
been for the project that I've been
doing about fundamental physics part of
that it's really useful to be able to
look at things in virtual reality
and I've been I didn't expect it to be
kind of an occupational hazard of doing
kind of basic physics research that I
would get motion sick in virtual reality
but I've been I've been finding that but
the the problem is that in virtual
reality to specify objects in three
dimensions and particularly to specify
how the objects relate to each other is
kind of complicated and so I mean this
is again so tech techie fact there isn't
really a great standard for how
three-dimensional objects are
represented in virtual reality there are
standards for 3d graphics and like in
Mathematica we support all of those
kinds of things but the most common
thing is using this system called unity
which is essentially a game making
system and putting things into unity and
we have a really good system for doing
that from Mathematica okay that was a
that was a um
a complicated question let me see what
time um ho boy we've got some okay we're
nearing the end of our time here but let
me look at a few other things here
there's a question from a Tory here can
we do computation not based on silicon
technology what really is computation
boy you shouldn't get me started on that
I've spent half my life studying that
question at least the second part of
that question what really is computation
um you know I talked about how in
computers you're just doing these logic
operations with Nan's and you're moving
ones and zeros around and you've got
these different opcodes and operations
that the computer does turns out you
don't need anything enough anything like
that complicated to make a computer I'll
show you I'll show you one of the
simplest computers I know let me um you
pull something up here um this is
actually a thing they share this than
once I couldn't
this is the simplest computer I know and
actually in many ways the simplest
computer that can exist this was a prize
I put up about 10 years ago for somebody
I had guessed that this was the sort of
simplest possible computer miss was a
prize for proving that really was a a
possible computer and a young chap in
England succeeded in doing that and and
won the prize I put up but this is this
is a thing that just gives it it's a
thing called the Turing machine named
after a chap called Alan Turing who
invented these the general idea of these
kinds of things in 1936 it's a very
idealized computer instead of having
electricity and and all that kind of
thing it just has a line of little
idealized cells and each idealized cell
in this case is either white yellow or
orange and at each cell it has this
little head that is either up or down
and so Alan Turing invented this kind of
idealization of computing that you could
do it in terms of just writing squares
on a tape and having this sort of place
single place where you put squares on
tape he actually invented that as a way
of imitating what people who were bank
clerks in those days used to do avina
you take some something out of a file
cabinet
you look at it you make an you do some
operation you write back another an
answer you put it back in the file
cabinet and so on he was kind of
idealizing that in a more theoretical
way and he came up with these things he
had much more complicated versions of it
but but that boil down to this so-called
Turing machine so this particular you
can have lots of different rules for
what you do when when they directly you
can have a head that's in you know a
thousand different possible positions
this one is in just two part different
possible positions States or two
different possible States up and down
you can have instead of just three
colors on the tape you could have a
hundred different colors on the tape but
you could ask the question what's the
very simplest collection of a very
simplest set of rules that would in
principle allow you to make any computer
do any computation out of
and this is the answer um and we know it
for a variety of other kinds of systems
not just Turing machines but we know
that in principle you could make a
computer just out of a sufficiently
large version of this and if you ran it
sufficiently long you could set it up so
that the initial arrangement of squares
of colors of squares on the on the
initial tape was some with such that you
could make it do any computation you
want in principle it might take billions
of steps and it might take billions of
squares on the tape but in principle you
can make it do any operation you want
and that's that's the that's fact that
you can do that is this idea of
universal computation and this is the
simplest thing that the simplest
underlying computer that lets you make
do universal computation so a question
is what could you implement this on I
mentioned that in silicon is very easy
to implement NAND operation so it's
least possible to implement land
operations so that's what all computers
are based on but let's imagine you had
something where you could implement this
little rule for a Turing machine you
could make a computer out of that well
it's a guess we don't know it it's a
guess that you might have be able to
have a single molecule that you could
make operate like this Turing machine
fact we already know that there are
things a little bit like that
in our in every cell in our body there
is this there's DNA which stores our
genetic code that our genetic program
but there's a when that genetic code is
transcribed it turns into RNA and then
there's little things called ribosomes
which kind of walk up and down the RNA
kind of generating proteins to actually
produce the things that are that make us
up um and those ribosomes well they
don't do they're not quite like Turing
machines but you could imagine them
being made to be like Turing machines
they're like this this head on the
Turing machine that goes back and forth
back and forth you could imagine
something like a ribosome that will be
sitting on a molecule going back and
forth back and forth and doing things um
we don't know how to make such a thing
right now but one could imagine being
able to make that um a molecular scale
computer that is that operates using for
example this particular universal
computer
it's something I've spent some
significant part of my life discovering
sort of very simple ways to do
computation like like this example for
the for the Turing machine here but one
of the things that that suggests is that
you can make computers out of almost
anything and you could for example make
molecular computers I mean right now the
only the the best sort of molecular
scale computer type thing that we have
is basically us our biology I mean
effectively biology can be thought of in
many ways as like a molecular scale
computer and it's it's the only example
we have really of that working but we
can certainly imagine in the future
being able to make molecular scale
computers that are sort of all of our
own design some people think we can sort
of piggyback on biology to use to use
DNA to make computers they don't think
it's the best way to do it um but I
think it'd be better if we could work
from scratch and make our own molecules
rather than having to have the molecule
that we've been sort of delivered by the
process of biological evolution over the
last few billion years so um in any case
there are look even at the level of
ordinary computers I should say that so
that's a very sort of futuristic
computers made of indium where the
computers are happening at the level of
individual molecules and so on there are
somewhat more prosaic versions somewhat
more simple-minded versions of that so
silicon is the most popular material to
make computers out of there are other
things gallium arsenide germanium are
other materials that people have made
computers out of another approach is
what quantum computers get made out of
those are often made well things like
things called Josephson junctions which
are are um well oh gosh
another thing I can talk about another
time if people are interested are things
called superconductors
which is what Josephson junctions are
made of um
all right let's see
all right I
going to I'm going to
take two more two more questions than
I'm wrapping up for here one is from
Tomah what do I think about virus
treatment advancements in the next ten
years will a pandemic treatment look
different than today what about general
vaccines better antiviral drugs etc you
know there is one futuristic thing that
might happen um well
first point is in terms of vaccines I
think I talked about a previous time
some things about how vaccines work but
essentially a vaccine has to present to
your immune system something that looks
like enough like the virus that your
immune system will react produce
antibodies produce the things it needs
to fight the virus if the virus showed
up for real and one of the things that
people sort of hope is that maybe
there'll be a sort of universal vaccine
that has a universal across a certain
class of viruses because there are
certain pieces of virus there are pieces
of its
of the proteins that contains the RNA it
contains that are things that never
occur as pieces of the cells that make
up our bodies but only occur in viruses
and if we could make sort of a vaccine
that says if ever anything that looks
like this if ever a sequence of amino
acids or a sequence of a piece of a RNA
or something shows up that looks like
this go attack it if we could find a
thing like that
that was existed on a bunch of viruses
but didn't exist on other cells in our
bodies or other kinds of cells that we
care about if we could make a vaccine
that just says anytime you see this you
know make the immune system fight it off
then that would allow us to have a more
universal vaccine that's it's not
realistic to do that across all possible
viruses because viruses have don't share
they don't universally it's not like
there's a thing that says on the on the
RNA sequence or the DNA sequence of a
virus there's not a little piece of it
that says I'm a virus and nothing else
each different kind of virus has a
different sequence the one that we're
fighting right now has just twenty nine
thousand bits effectively double bits in
its sum in its sequence and so but among
the costs of let's say influenza viruses
corona viruses whatever those classes of
viruses there might be the possibility
of having something which
every influenza virus we have a thing
that shows up in every influenza virus
and we mount an immune response we set
it up so that an immune response were
mounted whenever something which is just
that piece of just that thing which
exists in all influenza viruses
regardless of whether it's an h1n1 or a
you know and whatever it is a different
detailed flu flu virus shows up so
that's one approach a more out there
approach is something that um so so how
do drugs typically work so drugs are
typically molecules that have a chemical
activity with respect to some molecule
that exists in us that's the most common
kind of thing so what typically happens
is we are made mostly of proteins which
are these big long molecules and the big
long molecules have all kinds of
complicated shapes and the first
approximation a lot of drugs work by
finding some particular piece of that
shape where the drug molecule just fits
into that shape there are other ways
that some other kinds of drugs work but
of the think they're only about 1800
kinds of drugs that are the officially
approved collection of drugs that exist
in the world and of those a decent
fraction work the way that I'm saying
they basically though these long protein
molecules they have all these
complicated shapes the drug molecule is
the right shape to stick itself into
some opening or something in the protein
molecule and what that will do is it
will for example stop that protein from
working or it'll make the protein work
it'll do things like that they are they
they block the operation of the of the
protein or they enhance it or something
like that and they do it in this very
physical way they're just the molecule
is floating around and it finds it's
like kind of a lock-and-key type thing
the molecule sees that it can find it
can attach to what's called the binding
site and it will then you know lock into
the molecule that it's trying to deal
with and and do a particular thing and
so for example
in we might do that so that's the
typical way that existing drugs work
they are they're just they're these
molecules they fit sort of mechanically
into things like proteins
okay so there's another bizarre thing
you might be able to do that actually
relates to what I was just talking about
about molecular computers what if that
drug molecule was a little computer and
what if instead of just saying I'm you
know instead of just floating around and
if it's the right shape it fits imagine
that that molecule could actually in a
sense sense its environment do a
computation and say hey I I don't you
know I don't like this particular cell
it looks like it's been affected by a
virus I'm gonna go attack it let's say
that it could actually compute things it
could make measurements on the cell and
it could say okay it's got this feature
that feature and that feature and
therefore I'm going to do a piece of
logic to say so that means that cell is
is one that I should attack let's say
you could make essentially an
algorithmic drug or a computational drug
a a molecule that isn't just a static
molecule that binds to things but a
molecule that actually computes what to
do based on what it finds now at some
level things like the T cells in our
immune system are doing something a
little bit like that but we could
imagine that sort of the ultimate
antiviral type thing would be something
that can really do logic and in a way
that kind of enhances the logic that can
be done by our immune system to figure
out how to attack things and potentially
you know our immune system has to learn
to attack things by essentially a
process that's like biological evolution
that's like natural selection in us over
the course of time we are sort of
growing a collection of cells that are
optimized to attack the things that we
expect to attack us the things that
we've been vaccinated against or the
thing that we've seized things that
we've seen before and so on that we've
decided our are a bad bad molecules and
so on
so um yeah it's it's some Sandra on
livestream is commenting that um at some
point we should be able to have little
mini robots in our blood that could be
reprogrammed to Search and Destroy
particular intruders yes I think that's
that's what will eventually happen and
you know it'll be an interesting thing
because I mean at some level things a
little bit like that are being done with
some cancer treatments now but it's it's
some a long long story how all that
works I'd be happy to talk about it and
it's a little bit related to how CRISPR
and gene editing type the complicated
story let's not get into that another
time um all right and you know this
question about better virus testing and
so on I mean the you know the way that
you know we're we're testing for the
current term let's not get into that
again I can talk about how the different
testing method methodologies are working
now and what might be possible in the
future I'm gonna do one more question
here which is do scientists always use
metric units um you know
the Babylonians from 4000 years ago they
were the first folks who that we know of
who sort of systematized things and you
know before that time there were I'm
part of the reason they did that system
reservation is because they were
building cities and as soon as you have
a city you need to be able to do things
like say you know what's the area of
this piece of land and how does it
compare to that and need to have money
where you're counting things you need to
say this amount of barley is costs this
amount and this you know how big a
volume is of barley do we have well in
the past so that every city would have
its own system of units and even even
150 years ago there were different units
you know there was the I don't know
there you know the Berlin System of
Units the London System of Units you see
that particularly with amounts of mass
and volumes of things and even there
were different units for you know a mass
of bananas versus a mass of grapes
versus whatever else each different
thing had its own units and each
different city would have its own system
of units it's a little bit like in
today's world with money different
countries have different currencies you
can convert between them that those
conversions in the case of money because
slightly more complicated kind of thing
those conversions float and change in
the case of I have this load of bananas
it better be the case that that load I
shouldn't use the word bananas because
it really plays to my British accent and
sounds weird in American but let's say
oranges um apples you know we have this
load of apples and the and it better be
the case that that load of apples that
weighs you know 25 London pounds and it
weighs 23 Berlin pounds and so on that's
very confusing because you have to say
you know London pounds Berlin pounds and
so on anyway the first first time any of
that stuff was systematized that we know
of was by the Babylonians but then over
the course of time you know different
places systematized differently and
there was the
the so-called Imperial system of units
the system of units that was sort of
promoted by the British Empire was the
system of units that we have miles
inches feet I remember when I was a kid
the UM when I was a kid the the I grew
up in England and one of the things you
know England doesn't have a constitution
like the US Constitution or something
they did have a thing called Magna Carta
which was drawn up by a chap called King
John when he was trying to get his
barons just to to kind of be happy and
let him go on being King he and they had
to think of Magna Carta which was this
sort of their the the rule the laws of
the land or something and one of the
things that always confused me was a kid
I knew one of the provisions of Magna
Carta is that an inch would be the
length of the Kings thumb and I always
was very confused by that because it was
like well what if there's a different
King what if you know how does it well
of course actually King John probably
had a much smaller thumb than our modern
inch so it was a it was a it was a
fictional Kings thumb but nevertheless
it was that was kind of a an attempt to
standardize units in England with the an
inches the length of the Kings thumb
okay but so the system of units that was
used used in the in the countries that
were in the British Empire which
included the u.s. back a long time ago
were the imperial system of units which
were miles feet pounds all those kinds
of things the there was an attempt so in
France when Napoleon was in power in
France around 1800 the he decided to
commission a new system of units the so
called metric system of units and so he
tried to invent a sort of a perfect
system of units and his approach was for
example the meter was defined relative
to the the earth and a meter I think is
if you take the if you take the big the
great circle that goes through Paris and
goes around the earth through the North
Pole and South Pole and through Paris I
think a metre if I'm not mistaken it's 1
million
of the circumference of that circle if I
come if I'm not mistaken I might might
have that off by a little bit um but so
that was the definition of a meter that
Napoleon made and that was the metric
system that it was invented by Napoleon
um and the metric system had a lot of
good features for example everything was
based 10 um and you know it was in the
British system okay in the British
system there were a British system of
units you know there are 12 inches in a
foot three feet in the yard 1760 yards
in a mile it's a total mess of different
kinds of numbers
the Babylonians often used base 60 for
some reason in in the British imperial
system there were these different
factors you know even money used to work
that way when I was a kid in England in
the 1960s money worked this way there
were pennies the equivalent of cents in
American American cents pennies and
there were twelve my gosh am I
forgetting this there were twelve
pennies in a shilling and 20 shillings
and a pound okay so it was a non non
base ten system of units and none and I
used to say actually I remember telling
some teacher of mine when I was about
six or something years old I said this
is really stupid there's no reason to do
it this way you could perfectly well
have money work with you know with
multiples of ten and this teacher said
no no no it's been that way for a
thousand years it's gonna be that way
forever and I was like really and it
turned out just two years later Britain
announced that it was going to decimal
eyes that was going to turn its money
into being base 10 money that eventually
happened in 1970 it was actually
interesting I mean this is by the Hinn
or their but it might be amusing for
people the what what happens when you do
something like change the money from
being non decimal not based on on tends
to being decimal and I remember they
were running these television programs
about decimalisation where they were
trying to for about a year before hand
explaining people this
we'll work and they were very worried
about people are gonna be confused and
cetera et cetera et cetera and then
there was this actual day when the non
decimal money went out of circulation
the decimal money came into circulation
and it was kind of cool because you know
you you you got keep givin this old
money and you get back the new money and
the thing which was most notable to me
was people were not confused people were
very uncontested expected it to work
that way I thought you know people might
have been confused for a long time but
they weren't it was it was very very
fast
but in so in the System of Units the
imperial system of Units that's used in
the u.s. in England the it's not decimal
it's no it is for money now but but Tim
it's not decimal for things like lengths
and and you know and masses weights and
so on and that's that's awfully
inconvenient when you're doing sort of
mathematical type calculations I I might
say the following the one of the things
that I hope thought was interesting
about the decimalisation of English
currency it happened in 1970 I actually
mentioned earlier in this in this
discussion that calculators came in
roughly in 1970 and I actually believe
that if calculators had if if if Britain
had delayed decimal izing money for even
another two or three years it would
never have been decimalised because
doing calculations with non decimal
money is big nuisance big mess it's some
but if you'd had calculators to do it
everybody would have been able to do it
easily and so I suspect that there
wouldn't have been any motivation to
decimal eyes the money because the real
reason to decimalised was to make it
easier to do the calculations so the
original question here was do scientists
always use metric units the answer is
pretty much yes I mean there are some
other kinds of Units used in some areas
of science but in most areas of science
it's convenient to use decimal units
areas where it isn't in astrophysics
sometimes there are units like light
years and parsecs that are used which
are
turn aren't well aren't really decimal
in that in that they're not part of the
standard unit system I mean the thing to
understand is that they're all the units
for different kinds of things you know
the units of volume the units of there
are a certain number of basic units that
you have to specify and so in fact in
the in the standard way it's done its
sum the meter the kilogram and the
second the units of mass length and time
are sort of the most fundamental units
strangely there are a few other
fundamental units the unit of amount of
substance number of atoms in a mole unit
of the luminous intensity there all
sorts of arguments now about whether
angles should be fundamental units but
fundamentally the the three units that
are the three kinds of units that are
that are really fundamentally used on
mass length and time and you can derive
other things like volume is is length
times length times length length cubed
that's the units of volume and so on so
you can derive other units but but in
the sort of the most basic units that
you have to have a unit of length the
unit of mass in at a time if you should
get into fance it well no i let me not
go there in in fundamental physics
there's some new thinking about how that
might work but um I just my final
passing thing here is like how do we
measure in modern times you know back in
the days of Magna Carta we measured
length in terms of supposedly in England
the length of the Kings thumb um how do
we measure length mass time now they're
all actually measured in terms of
features of atoms until very recently
until just a couple of years ago the way
that kilograms were ultimately measured
is using a particular metal kilogram
that was sitting in a vault in Paris I
believe that was the kilogram the
standard kilogram and they were copies
of it in different places and if you
wanted to know absolutely for sure did
you have exactly one kilogram of mass
you could in principle go and take that
thing out of the vaults in Paris and
find out if it was the same mass as the
thing you had I think it got taken out
of its boat once a deck
or something and had to be very
carefully controlled but anyway it's
much better to measure everything in
terms of properties of atoms and that's
what is now being done everything mass
length and time are all measured in
terms of properties of atoms um and well
probably have atoms together with the
speed of light
um and the reason that's a good thing is
because every let's say atom of caesium
or atom that happens to be one that's
used but every atom of carbon or
whatever every single atom of carbon is
exactly the same it's a remarkable
feature of physics that you know it's
not the case if you have a big lump of
metal there lots of different lumps of
metal we can make but every single
carbon atom that exists in the universe
is essentially the same and that means
that if we use it as our way to make
measurements of things like we use it as
a unit of mass for example it's this
number of carbon atoms or something it's
not quite how it works but let's say it
was that um then we can be sure that
wherever we make this measurement it
will always be the same and as I'm
saying that I'm realizing that I really
should be qualifying that in terms of
things about the effects of gravity and
general Authority and all kinds of fancy
things like that which we're not going
to talk about here now all right well
that was fun for me I hope people found
that interesting and I will potentially
do more of these please give us feedback
on what was used for what wasn't I'm
actually this Thursday I'm going to do
something a little bit like this I'm
going to talk specifically about physics
and I'm going to talk about the history
of physics and okay the the the very
careful observer will realize that maybe
I'm talking about the history of physics
because I'm hoping next week to talk
about more things about the future of
physics but anyway this week I'm going
to talk about the history of physics and
I'll try and give a a kind of an outline
of kind of the whole history of physics
from antiquity to just sort of the
present day and I'm that will be I hope
at a fairly elementary level um and be
happy to have questions and things there
but um
for coming today and I'll sign off from
from this okay